so I will give you an outline of my
presentation I will give you a brief
introduction and some example of
extracellular vesicles heterogeneity and
then I will focus the rest of my work on
blood on cousins and until you my career
my view on the potentials that we have
by studying an exerciser vesicles for
biomarkers development and extracellular
vesicles are membrane enclosed particles
that can vary in size they can be very
very small to the level of few
nanometers and we can be very large
reaching over 10 micron in diameter and
they can be released by any living
organism in the universe and can be
identified immobile for the fluids
because they are secreted actively dying
cells the this is an interesting review
that was published in 2009 by American
Gucci and really signed the switch of
Elena because the exercise of vesicles
have been studied for several decades
but it's still only in the last five to
ten years that people have become more
and more aware of the importance of this
accessible vesicles and excluded that
there is no they are not enough found in
the exercise of vesicles play a distinct
function often highly specialized
function that time to reflect the
function of the originating sell these
functions include the ones that are
written here and as far as cancer is
concerned
exercise I vesicles have been
demonstrated to play function in
transmission under jerrazis metastasis
transfer of practice systems etc there
is a wide range of extracellular
vesicles operation that if there's not
only in size but also in function
biogenesis and mechanism of
communication with target cells and we
all know now that different cell types
release different population of excess
of escorts in each cell can release a
different types of Elise this is a an
editorial that was published last year
in the Journal of extracellular vesicles
by the International Society for
extracellular vesicles which I am an
executive board member and i highly
suggest to lead this editorial because
it really deals with the importance to
approach the field well knowing what are
the covers and what are what is the
complexity of the excess of your
vegetables and I think that's a good way
to start especially for people who are
new to the field in a way that is not
frustrating and it allows to understand
how to study the complexity of
extracellular vesicles at the best and
this figure here shows that the letters
in an incredible increase of
publications on extracellular vesicles
which have gone by different names or
including XSL microvesicles and others
especially since 2005 when the field is
really a bill of roaming and we
understand more and more about these
vesicles
these are three seminal papers that were
published in the world in 2007-2008 by
the Kroc Center brakefield mm locked
well and be honest track and they all in
vitro cell biology and I just wanted to
point out that these papers have been
sighted all together more than 5,000
times in only seven to eight years and
they all brought up the earth focused on
the importance of these XSL vesicles
that can be released by tumor cells and
other type of cells and transfer RNA and
genomic information with which English
is functional changes in recipient cells
also these two papers are very important
and they are much more recent they were
published from David Dryden group in
2012 and 2015 respectively and they
really live be polite very nice you'd be
more evidence of the role of the
exosomes from melanoma cell in the first
paper which are able to prepare the
payment of static niche through
activation of med signaling pathway and
in the second paper which was published
earlier on this year they even
demonstrate the tumor exosomes contains
surface molecules in particular selected
classes of immigrants that are
responsible of the homing to the
metastatic side of the origin or cell
from which these vesicles originate
suggesting and confirming an incredibly
important functional role of SC first
one of the pioneer in the field and one
of the most active scientists in
extracellular vesicles as being such an
equal to three and I bumped in this time
we were few days ago and by hair which
has is
question in a provocative title are all
excellent equal and they just want to
use this slide to take advantage of this
review to point out that it's turning
out that even if you isolate
specifically exosomes you can see that a
different exosomes exhibit different
classes of molecules which is intuitive
in a way because if we meet in that the
cells release these vesicles
continuously and we receive you'll know
exactly what are the mechanisms of
selection of cargo to one or another
type of vesicles of course not all
accidents will carry the same
information and that's why it is
important to study them as a population
that is very very vivid these are
additional two studies from a Richard
Simpson group in Australia in the first
paper they identify by mass spectrometry
two distinct population of exosomes
released by colon cancer cells and in
the follow-up paper that was published I
think this year it was one they realize
that this to population of accessible
receivers can actually be even great
more clearly separated in three of three
populational vesicles by profiling the
micro irony of these vesicles suggesting
again that when we isolate or it's very
important to keep in mind that whatever
method we isolate for purification of
these vesicles we will end up with a
mixture of vesicles but and this is very
important and I just want to take a
moment to mention that there are several
tips that have been commercialized and
some of them are very useful to have a
very quick analysis of these external
vesicles however it is important
to start it on the difference between
this is excellent icicles because each
of them might contain different
information there are this another study
from la Stella crashed earlier in the
unlocked all grouped in Gothenburg a
study that was performed in
collaboration with it it pulls us in in
Budapest and it was published in the
Journal of exercise vesicles and they
the other side n tified distinct profile
of Indiana Avenue contained in apoptotic
bodies microvesicles and EXO songs
suggesting again that there are
different population of extracellular
vesicles as far as the size is concerned
there are definitely other is left a
wide range of a pea size and it here on
the Left we have an example of exosomes
this is a very well-known inmate from
you on stock but was punched in yourself
a large in 2008 the big thing is a cell
completely filled with texts ohms and
which can only be visible by electron
microscopy on right we have live jumper
songs that i will talk to you more in
detail in stable this is a 10 micron
size so you as you can see the large on
croissants also in the in the lower
schematic very large and they almost
reach the the diameter of sales these
are other images of large on Cozens we
know now that this
vesicles can arise from non apoptotic
membrane plants we performed several
experiments to exclude the possibility
that the cells were undergoing apoptosis
and as you can see we can visualize them
not totally on the plasma membrane of
the tumor cells but they are also shared
in the surrounding environment which
made us thinking that we could isolate
them for to study them and this is a
scheme from a value that was averaged in
2008 that illustrate how the mechanism
do the basic lichens not membrane ready
which we still don't know enough about
however it seems that the the blood
arise for a passive mechanism when the
fibrillary acting cortex is ruptured and
there is because there is an increase of
the hydrostatic pressure in the
cytoplasm and is the very means of
formation of the web and only mine the
fiber already acting reference that
because it's by an active mechanism that
involves activation of relay and dock
Tiny's with consequent phosphorylation
of miles in to lightshade there is a
retraction of the lessee course and it's
this continues for measurement
retraction of vesicles that confers the
ability to migrate to these very
aggressive unemployed to ourselves we
published a few studies in the last
seven years this is work that was
performed as a collaboration between my
doom and Michael Freeman group and we
demonstrated that Blanca songs can be
released by migratory amid volume cells
which are really the very aggressive and
metastatic tumor cells as a consequence
of constitutive activation of akt of
expression of korean won also egfr
activation induces the phenomenon and
importantly we demonstrated that mu
silencing of dial 3 which is a
diaphragms related for me which is
involved in active nucleation and
skeletal population also induce the
phenomenon pretty dramatically and we
demonstrated in this cancer research
paper in collaboration with turning 13
at the Broad Institute that the locals
on which directory is codified on
chromosome 13 is frequently cumulative
in metastatic prostate cancer but not in
in local disease suggesting that this is
an important phenomenon in advanced
prostate cancer and i just want to
mention because i'm not going to show
you many data on different type of
tumors that we now know that larger
cousins are produced by any type of
tumor not only by prostate cancer we
went on and attempted to identify these
large autosomes in situation and
initials taking advantage of their
larger size we first use the mouse model
of prostate cancer in which we
demonstrated that a human one positive
large vesicles in the size range between
1 and 10 micron and the events were
counted and quantified by flow cytometry
using specific size beads we
demonstrated that there was a
correlation between the number of these
vesicles and the presence of metastases
in the mouse and we also attempted to
perform a similar experiment in human
plasma and we demonstrated that this
kuvira one positive events were
significantly increased in patients with
castration-resistant metastatic disease
in comparison with patients with the
indolent prostate cancer which is very
important
prognostic and I want to also mention
that the experiment on the human plasma
was performed using filtration and
mental get my thermal air lock in the
lab set up a few years ago and with this
methodology we could perform this
experiment by using us only 200
microliters of plasma then we went to
the tissues and we use psycho Garrett in
18 which nicely stained plasma membrane
of the tumor cells over here and we we
could see using two different tissue
microarray in collaboration with Mark
Rubin at Cornell Medical Center that the
feature is feature which is the presence
of large vesicles in tissue sections
again correlates with increased little
score and metastasis and it's absolutely
an absent in benign tissue we also have
some evidence by electron microscopy
that we can visualize these vesicles in
vicious little sections of the dreamers
and as you can see here at higher
magnification we can also see the
structure of recess opposed by electron
microscopy indistinct to contain Kali
ribosomes if not other organelles I'm
sure you now the study that was recently
published earlier on this year on which
river for proteomic analysis using
asylum quantitative approach of large
autosomes versus exosomes that I from
the same cancer cell and we used as a
model a prostate cancer cell in which
directly was knocked down knowing that
as highly
high rate of Uncas and Chevy and this
was an experiment to confirm that in the
dietary knockdown cells we have an
increased number of vesicles laughter
than one micron and even more vesicles
larger than two micron completely our
biggest results so we we used the silac
approach and what we found was that the
poor cup contains identify the laptop
for some NX sauce was actually the same
and seventy-five percent of the profits
exhibit similar levels however one point
twenty-five thirty percent of the profit
we're either uniquely identified in
either type of vesicles or they were
significantly after unity one in the
exosome or large testicles and as a
confirmation of a world of what is known
in excellence we found a cpa t1c benign
and other proteins that are commonly
identified in exosomes whereas the
proteins that were mostly identified in
XO tools were enzymes that have been
involved in different important
metabolic processes in cancer when we
perform the functional analysis using
the hundred tool in collaboration with
the light body / matakana at the y
electrode university in manville we
notice that the apt is that were
significantly upregulated in the
proteins and reached in blood vessels
where metabolism of carbohydrates and
gluconeogenesis and glutamine
mcCaffery's whereas the apt words that
were enriched in the vesicle in the
small vest in the complaint sandwiched
in small vesicles add more to do with
integrals and
funny commercial proliferation as it is
known for exosomes we validated by
western blot the impeachment of some of
these proteins in our large population
of vegetables in this case will at got
one year 63 was used as an excess of
marker and we also demonstrated that God
one can actually be transferred for the
secant cells exposed to the vesicles and
this is not an effect due to increase
RNA synthesis as it is shown here by the
levels of RNA remain constant after
treatment we also perform the functional
experiment because we are seeing this
enrichment of enzymes particularly
important in glutamine metabolism we
expose recipient ourselves to the larger
problems and to the exomes and for the
last activity assay or got one activity
assay and we notice that the large top
results were able to induce a loop of
circulation of this assay and this was
not elicited by exercise we then perform
several experiments in collaboration
with yun seunga austech University in
South Korea to try to understand what
where the physical characteristics of
these vesicles and we used your dicks
and all centrifugation ingredients and
flotation of the pellets that we need
obtained by total centrifugation that
are commonly used to significant very
small particles and larger particles so
everybody I guess is Camilla with the
fact that when we usually let down the
Arctic
we perform a first low speed auto
identification to to get rid of cell
fragments and entire in themselves and
then we use a 10,000 g alternative
addition to pellet down that the
vesicles and then the supernatant go
through another round the horses
interrogation at 100,000 g we usually
also use filters of 200 nanometers so
that in the pellet we already have this
nodal accidents below 200 anomaly but
what we did in this experiment we took
the pellets the 100,000 g and the 10,000
g fella and we floated them on these
gradients and in the exosome pellet we
were able to celesta course that segment
it at 110 and 150 gram per ml which is
the density of the exercise our industry
neural net external gradient and they
expressed sg-11 and see dat one which
are markers of exosomes commonly
identified in exosomes and the electron
microscopy compared the nature of these
testicles when we floated the 10,000 g
vesicles instead we notice that the
density of the particles was actually
very similar to the density of the
exosome sand with particles identifiable
at 12 10 1 15 gram per ml but the
expression markers were completely
different and we we focus on some
proteins that we have identified by mass
spectrometry and we use only
immunofluorescence to identify is
particles by immunofluorescence as one
of the proteins that we identified and
that could be anything useful biomarker
we have cytokeratin 18 which was in the
top 5 percentile of the proteins
identified in large vesicles and we went
on a
thank you to perform western blot with
an antibody against psychedelic enmity
in vesicles extracted from the plasma of
patients with prostate cancer and
controls for this experiment we use the
XO week which is a very commonly used
get to a let down extracellular vesicles
and any other material attached to them
so the key is not specific for any type
of exercise of vesicles that if you are
if you want to have that idea of what
you're what you're getting is good and
in our case we had already demonstrated
and cytochemical meeting was specific
for large autosomes so indeed experiment
we demonstrate that psychotherapy
nicotine is significantly upregulated in
the plasma of patient with prostate
cancer with it with experimental
collaboration with the mr tumbling some
guns and martin glebe at the vancouver
prostate cancer center we also use an
animal model we had previously performed
alum metastases us say in mice subjected
to injections of prostate cancer cells
with and without die of three knockdown
and when we use site therapy meeting
early too early as a unity and affinity
purification market for luxury suppose
we notice an increase of these vesicles
in the plasma of mice with directly
silence cells metastases and these are
some sections of lung metastases high
magnification showing indicated by the
red arrows a lot of these features that
prison or large condoms this is a
conclusive slide from this story that
illustrates that if we if we focus on
the opens the toil in which the least
four times in the large opposition
compare
with accidents this protein some of them
are engaged 20 times or even 40 times
and more they are all involved in
prostate cancer progression metastasis
resistance that IV therapy resistance to
docetaxel chemotherapy so again this day
are all point out the possibility that
the content and function of this large
on cousin is very important in tumor
progression and metastasis this data
were analyzed all together by Sandy mu
computational biologists from South
Korea join our group of humans room so
what after our studies on large of
results only our world has been
confirmed by several papers and I'm
seeing more and more frequently
descriptions of large festivals and this
is a very distant paper that was
published last year in oncogene in which
they show a large vesicles in the
diameter of the laptop persons that can
be released by avid for ourselves during
motility and the paper on doubt to the
fact that the characteristic of this
anabolic migration is the continuous
formation and reproduction of memory
breaths we still don't know how the
memory plants that form and retract at
some point are shed from the vesicles
and there is still a lot of work that is
necessary in this field there are
several studies including this very
recent studies published by the group of
christening the supershow words
describing tumor-derived my collectibles
from highly invasive and unfold platinum
cells and there are some very nice
mechanistic insights in this service
that again point out to the importance
of research
and to the need to understand the
biogenesis and their cargo better and
finally on along same lines and this is
a paper that was published at the end of
last year and where there is a
description of the Mayas own a new
extracellular organelle that is formed
in himself during their migration so we
still known oil are similar all these
large vesicles are with each other and
we need to do experiments to understand
that however it is a significant that
there are more and more of these large
vesicles identified for some reason they
it has been more difficult to identify
the larger vesicles than small vesicles
however this large mexican star clearly
visible in by by simple microscopy we
recently wrote a review that should come
up not sold that really highlights all
the names that have been used for large
vesicles and again it would be
interesting to study them better because
there are a few informations about
caracal at the moment and pathways that
elicit the formation of these vesicles
but there is still a lot to be
understood and this is a figure from the
same drive view that illustrates again
how to ourselves can I use different
type of extracellular vesicles from the
very large large on Cozens to EXO
microvesicles and exercise and these
vesicles can all affect the recipient
cells in the tumor microenvironment in
different ways and one other thing that
contributes to the complexity into the
diversity of excellent vesicles is that
the cells in the tour Michael
can then react to the messages delivered
by the tumor cells and it is other
extracellular vesicles that can transfer
important information I'll show you now
someone unpublished data from our lab
this is work from Valentina mean Chucky
a graduate student in the lab she
demonstrates that she can identify
extracellular vesicles interested in
cells that can pick them up very easily
by microscopy of the vesicles are
stained with a liquid dye which is
fluorescently labeled and we can see the
diameter of these vesicles is very large
just to remind on and I would be careful
when images of this kind are showing for
exosomes because it varies a possibility
that the population of exercises that
have been collected contained also
larger vessels otherwise they wouldn't
be visible by common on confocal
microscopy or immunofluorescence
microscopy given the low resolution of
the majority of the instruments we can
follow a vesicle uptake by flow
cytometry and the uptake of the Resta
course coral is correlated with the
number of vessels that we use are
indicating that this is a specific
phenomenon we have other data for
children this is a specific phenomenon
but leaving the rest of the time I'm not
gonna go through all of them
specifically we use the system of the
street cancer cells overexpressing
illustratively 50 and we notice that
when we isolate large on croissant and
exercise from these tumor cells first of
all the active form of a case in which
is phosphorylated it's actually mainly
localized in the large uncle Soames with
very low signal in the XO's owns these
are our
laptop was on Marky and Nexus or markers
we use another cell two different cell
lines basically and 2012 we want to
demonstrate that to test whether
phosphated he was also present in cells
that one of an expressive Pacific
Atlantic form of the protein and this is
the case and the cooking is up please
expressly large on reasons we then
performed kinase assay which i think is
the first time kinase assays performed
directly in extracellular vesicles that
were isolated from the cell media and
culture in sylvania and we show that a
lot of the large on persons contain
costs for a kitty and the kinase was
very stable and we could identify it
also after 24 hours of culture of these
vessels suggesting again that is
specific and harmful of proteins that
can anticipate their functional effects
for a long time 24 hours in the bolian
could be a long time oui oui this is a
clinically relevant and I apologize if
this Western bloc did not come out for
some reason there is a problem with
commercial but fortunately we have an
all this Western blot of different
patient plasma in which we show that
possibility circulates in the large on
cousins and is not protectable in the
exomes and I think it is very important
if we think about using these exercises
vesicles as biomarkers and we get three
from large and vegetables than the
signal that we might identify in Exeter
and small I'm a functional point of view
Valentina tested the level of large on
persons in the tube formation which is
something that has been used to test the
function of exosomes and we confirmed
that exosomes cannon use a robust
activation of tube formation in inverted
ourselves but we noticed that large on
presume are coming with a much stronger
signal and what was even more striking
was that when we treated the yogic cells
not directly with X's on one presumes
but with the conditioned medium plastic
fiberglass exposed to excellence or
alert uncle Soames only the conditioned
medium from the fiberglass exposed to
large uncle Soames could induce a
significant population suggesting that
these large vesicles might have
different functions than exosomes and
might be important messengers not only
in the cell-to-cell communication but
also in cancelling information from one
cell to another for a real complex
croscill as what happens in cancer we
now know that again there are different
types of vesicles they are michael s
suppose there are extra souls and these
large uncle Soames while we still don't
know much about the mechanism of
communication used by the left on for
some sweet the tumor microenvironment
but we are currently studying them and
i'm not going to show you this data that
we now have also understood the
mechanism of uptake of large on persons
from ourselves in the micro environment
and we can modulate this by using
facility source which is going to be
very important also parenthetically but
we face a lot known about the role of x
and Mike Alessi course in the tumor
microenvironment a lot of work
especially from a late flight on in
jizan weather on the function of
tgf-beta and one important discovery as
being that from this group as in the
till tgf the existing but a sample for
and a vesicle bound for and it seems to
play a different function depending on
whether it's secretly the soluble
molecules over not moving on i also want
to show this paper it's a very
interesting paper that was published by
stefano pouquinho group at the end or
last year even if it's not cancer and
it's focused on a neural stem cell model
it shows and i really apologize for the
image on the left bottom that overlaps
with something else it is again a
technical issue but if you can see the
homicide got basically ever they realize
that there are two different vesicles
which are smaller and larger and they
they see that reactivation of signaling
downstream pathway in the second cell is
stronger elicited by excellent by this
is standard than the signaling actually
elicited by x ourselves and i think this
is important again exosomes might have
some very Kim and very specialized
functions however we won concert to keep
behind this deflected vesicles can
incorporate a larger number of molecules
and this could have important functional
impact so in the last part of the talk
abou guna on
on the possibilities that we are by
studying access Alana supposed to
develop biomarkers another using a
scheme from a very nice travel from a
young shark in montreal in canada at
mcgill university and basically what we
can do and this is true for their brain
tumors but it's true also for other type
of tumors we can extract the plasma from
the body and there are several groups
that are working on the standardization
of these procedures and creating SOP
that can be distributed to all
investigators and this is a very
important process and then we can
isolate different type of vesicles
including autosomes and enter for
downstream access because we now know
that these vesicles containing only
proteins but also nucleic acids and we
can use new proteomic tools and
next-generation sequencing to
characterize the vegetables one
challenge email has been a long time in
proteomic in mass spectrometry the fact
that there is a large dynamic claimed in
terms of protein expression in in the
plasma and some of the most abundant
proteins are albumin and I mean they're
plasma proteins that don't have to do
anything with the quick maskers tumor
markers that we are trying to identify
which is usually in these this age so I
think it's very important to consider
that the mass spectrometry is
is significantly progressing then there
are more and more sensitive methods that
we can use today and isolating
population of vesicles that are
specifically released from the tumors is
probably helpful in the future to
discover biomarkers and I want to thank
great young my colleague cedars-sinai
with whom I've been working for several
years and was in terrific in helping me
understanding now we can start with a
pollutant content on extracellular
vesicles but the future is really moving
I mean removing also very fast as a fuel
and there are several studies especially
from Holly and lost my seller who are
leaders reverse field well develop
different types of microfluidic
platforms that allow the separation of
specific types of extracellular vesicles
within seconds and from very small
volumes of plasma like few microliters
of plasma and this is a snapshot of a
study that we read performing in
collaboration with the novel I and
others at mgh and i'll just go very
quickly through what i want to show that
and basically we use half holy
microfluidic device to and when we and
we show that egfr will be three which is
a which is a mutant egfr which has three
other significance in bio blastoma is an
identifiable port in large on croissants
and in exosomes and uses the exosome
marker and it Lisa
which is not I'm expressing our junk
results the other was able to show
similar results by real-time pcr in the
plasma of mice with the new 87 egfr with
three xenografts and again with happily
with demonstrated that the plasma of
these mice contain large amounts of egfr
victory in the large festivals as well
as in the small vegetable so one other
message is that we cannot just separate
them and study them as if they were
completely different and distinct
entities there are population of
vegetables that currently same type of
information especially when the other
two months in the last few minutes I
want to show another couple of snapshots
of government work and I'm just giving
you the punchline the papers are in
Revelation but it all has to do with the
effort on liquid biopsy and it's
becoming more and more important to
start the plasmid env for example in the
circulation and this is very important
because biopsies are inclusive and they
are not always possible so several
groups I've been working on not easy for
the extracellular vesicles contain DNA
these are papers published by Jonas luck
and by the enola a lie which reported
they were among the first studies
reporting the presence of DNA in
extracellular vesicles and these are two
more recent studies one from kahului
group and one from david lyon and actor
another again which show that exosomes
can actually contain genomic DNA
it's all chromosomes and specific
mutations or agility from the tour's
what we are doing we are using a
comparative approach again and when we
look at the total amount of
single-stranded and double strand DNA in
the plasma of myself tumors we can see
that the majority of the DNA is actually
enclosed in La Jolla zones with a small
portion of DNA in Alexis ohms we now
have an additional tool that can be very
useful and we need to understand how to
use it more efficiently which is the ton
of voyeuristic offensive or see which
allows us to not totally visualize and
quantify and measure articles in
diameter of non-lethal but also particle
in the diameter of micro medium which we
know include the large on prisons we
perform next generation sequence or
genome analysis and we show that the
profile of the pc 3 cancer cell is very
similar to the profile of the larger
cousins they are from distance we can
also identify translocation by using
this method and by problem pcr we can
demonstrate and validate our
next-generation sequencing data and
identify specific somatic copy number
aberrations earn in the in the uncles
that are present in the originating
cancer cell the last snapshot is on our
name we have among fitting in operation
in which we show that the content in RNA
of large uncle is again more abundant
than in exosomes weaken fear with the
large chompers on an extra zone entity
by using markers and what we look at the
look for all RNA sequencing Emily
including and what we see is that the
repairs that can be identified enlarge
on persons are five times more than what
we can identify in exosomes and the
libraries and also on better qualities
undulant profile analyzes profile data
showing the profile of DNA which is very
different in the two type of vesicles
and the original selves again the
take-home message is not is to not
exclude larger particles from livery
preparations because the larger particle
still is my cancer sensor can be very
important the last concept I want to
give and just to mention that there are
also my product name is Mike arrest as
we all know very well so we can we score
my progeny that is significantly
upregulated in large on koszalin
vegetables come from ourselves not from
the nine cells and will have the ability
obviously to express it in cells and
when we all express it themselves and we
then look at the larger force on an
accessory distribution we can see that
the micro janu is abundantly transferred
into these vesicles where it can play
then we can start in the specific
functions and we are in distorted miss
studying the functions of my progeny
containing extracellular vesicles in the
immune response to the tumor and i think
is important to consider that there are
some large festivals this is a new
interesting paper that was published
last year by manish tewari group again
yes and it was the first pontiff even
spoke American ally
might return the content of exosomes and
one of the results of these papers is
that there is not enough room enough
space in each single exosomes to contain
several copies of it even my progeny but
what I think I think is a very important
resultant we have to absolutely consider
when we study population of
extracellular vesicles we study them it
is a complex range of x equals not a
single molecules yet and there are
definitely larger vesicles that could
accommodate more material I take the
opportunity to invite everybody to our
annual and international society of
extracellular vesicles meeting which
will be in Japan in the Netherlands this
year in next year in me and basically
and ideal venue where there will be
about 1,000 delegates they are all eager
to learn more on external vesicles or
they are making an expert signal I hope
to Italy recommend this and I'm going to
unload it all present and past
collaborators on this project and in
particular people in my life and yeah
our collaborators at cedars-sinai or
innocent places and thank you for your
attention i'm gonna switch to learn
people questions
so so it seems that there is a question
from Simona how do I demonstrate that
got one found in the second cells into
us is censored by a low and not being
used by any other electronics activated
upon a log treatment I don't think we
can exclude that and we were the only
experiment that we it was to exclude
that there was a a synthesis of God's
the one starting from other day and that
is not the case so we can't believe that
the propane is transferred there are
several other aliases in the literature
that foldings can be faster to deceive
yourselves the other question is are we
demonstrated by density gradient in
plasma sound or step cytokeratin a whom
is exclusive to a low and not other
vegetables no this is a very interesting
question since we had gone of all the
bad cop experiments in vitro we did not
do this in vivo I don't believe it is an
important experiment to perform there
are things in plasma that we have to be
very aware of including apoptotic bodies
and platelet-derived extracellular
vesicles that could be in a similar size
range to the large on persons and we are
starting the project in collaboration
with idiot who service with an expert of
apoptotic bodies at University of
Budapest to really time to distinguish
between the two type of Mexico so so in
the plasma there is another question
from an arrow UK and asking or silk
class myself Indian may derive from this
extracellular vesicles so this is also
very interesting question we are working
on this topic with Francesca the
McCandless at University of Trento and
girth a car in London what seems to be
the case so far when we separate
jon kassan exosomes and then we take the
supernatant from the plasma after
clicking it from extracellular vesicles
there is a very small component of DNA
in the extracellular vesicles free
fraction and we don't believe that it is
important to also try to understand what
if there is a different diversity in the
content of the DNA which is really
floating in the Gosnell versus one that
is enclosed in vesicles and I believe
that it's also important to
differentiate between large on cousin
which are certainly derived from the
full moon and the exercise which can be
derived by any type of cell in the body
when we do this downstream analysis
which could allow asked when a better
understanding of our to improve our
approach to the liquid biopsy there is
another question from Tihar asking
output the different apoptotic and runa
cathodic black bean I already touched on
that as far as the plasma is concerned I
can also say that we are referred
several experiments in vitro and there
are it's very something we have to keep
in mind about logic bodies and rich
sizes similar to the ones of
extracellular vesicles become low power
in liters I visit since very clear that
this blending was a mekinese as other
people have demonstrated that is used by
ourselves we migrate and not to undergo
apoptosis there are more questions I'm
not sure I was doing with the time are
not uncle Sol associated to our
operations this is a question from
Carlos I yet to say that we don't know
that we have not looked into that
it's interesting to consider and it's
definitely possible at the moment that
any type of alteration in any also
increase I to select membrane could lead
to alteration of the formation of this
vesicles even if the vesicles seem to be
released by the plasma membrane we do
know that they internalize content found
the site applause and we don't know if
there is anything in the here are in
this folding proteins or even in nuclear
la Mina's structure alterations that
bring that elicit is phenomenal there is
another question from rolls asking
bleating is Excel reticles will also
send that signals to other cells in
response to chemotherapeutic agents
learning to think I didn't really think
about this what we know and we have also
eliminated data in the lab of the
reserve an apt in literature from
several groups now what we know is that
there is a the XSL vesicles that we
ability to comes resistance to
chemotherapeutic reagents why they're
big emotional comes I think it's very
possible that the cells that can capture
and not more sensitive to the
chemotherapeutic agent can also
elaborate piece and then speak it out in
form of other extras and vegetables I
think is going to be the last question
how done which isolation method
you should differential expression of
fossil akt an impatient drive and low
versus access also i forgot to mention
thank you for reminding me these we have
used our differential certification
protocol for love by octave reputation
so this is a different from papers that
might have been published without very
accurate separation between exes on a
large on persons so we and I want to
find out that when since we have applied
this is optical gradient and rotation we
have seen much more robust results
because it is important and and and
currently these are still the most
standardized method to separate the
vesicles and in a way that they they get
cleave they get cleaned from any
attached to material so we can give this
on your function specifically so i think
we are finished with the question thank
you everyone for your attention i'm
going to switch to Randy to wrap this up